[Music]
what sense do women prefer the most on
men studies fine that we tend to choose
fragrances that work best with our body
odors we also tend to gravitate
romantically toward the smell of those
who have certain genes that differ from
our own the theory is that we are
subconsciously attracted to mates who
would produce children with stronger
immune systems according to a 2010 study
by dr. Alan Hirsch of the smell and
taste treatment and Research Foundation
the most popular scent preferences can
vary by geography dr. Hirsch surveyed
the female population within various US
cities to find what scent do women
consider the most attractive and here
are some of his findings New York City
women were most attracted to the scent
of coffee women from Minneapolis favored
the scent of fresh-cut grass
while Atlanta women preferred the scent
of cherry and women from San Diego were
actually most drawn to the scent of
suntan lotion and the ocean while women
in Phoenix favored eucalyptus and one of
the most attractive cents to Los Angeles
women was found to be lavender the sense
of patchouli frankincense ginger
lavender lime orange and rose have
historically been considered
aphrodisiacs and Chicago women favored
vanilla the wide popularity of certain
smells like vanilla black pepper and
cinnamon may be due to their ability to
increase oxygen to the brain which can
have a positive effect on mood energy
levels and hormones Houston women found
one of the most attractive cents to be
barbecue and finally in Philadelphia
women found the most attractive scent to
be clean laundry
what's your favorite scent
[Music]